hello all again I hope you all enjoyed
your Eastern speaking of the death of
Christ David Hayter is not going to be
the voice of snake aka Big Boss and
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain now
a lot of people are in an uproar and I
understand the uproar but here are my
thoughts on the fact that David Hayter
has not been called back to voice the
voice of big boss David Hayter if you
didn't know has been the voice of Solid
Snake and Naked Snake for all of the
Metal Gear Solid games there gonna be
some spoilers and my thoughts on this
right here from Metal Gear Solid Force
if you haven't played for and you plan
on it don't listen to this I say Naked
Snake and not Big Boss because David
Hayter did not play the voice of big
boss at the end of Metal Gear Solid 4
that was Richard Doyle David Hayter
played the voice of Solid Snake and
young big boss David Hayter still played
the voice of Old Snake
Richard Doyle played the voice of old
big boss so I always talk to myself at a
point in big boss's life if they keep
going along with these games there has
to be a point where big boss sounds less
like David Hayter and more like Richard
Doyle that just that's just what the
facts say in terms of the voice actors
they got for the roles and now David
Hayter is not the voice of big boss now
I'm not saying this is why this is what
I'm telling myself anyway but if this
game takes place nine years after Big
Boss went into a coma if you're gonna
make Big Boss a different character then
snake and not have the two sound alike
which you have established in previous
games that that has to happen I guess
this would be the time for it so I guess
I'm saying I understand why David haters
not in the game I hate that I want
nothing more than to just sit here and
rant about the fact that David Hayter is
not going to be snake in this game or
Big Boss rather and I know the natural
response to this is well the Japanese
voice actor they've had to play snake
thus far does play Big Boss and Metal
Gear Solid 5 the Japanese version that
is in which case my response would be
maybe the Japanese voice actor they've
had to play snake sounds like the
Japanese voice actor they got to play
Big Boss in Metal Gear Solid 4 I can't
qualify that if I'm being completely
honest with you I am terrible at telling
Japanese voices apart that's just an
honesty I'm giving you if you had
Japanese voice actor 1 2 & 3 lined up
and they all said the same line then I
close my eyes and they shuffle around it
and they say the same line again I
wouldn't be able to tell you which one
was 1 2 or 3 I would fail that miserably
I do know this though David Hayter
sounds nothing like Richard Doyle at all
so this might have been the case of the
casting agent who cast the American
voices may have screwed David Hayter out
of being in Metal Gear Solid 5 by
casting Richard Doyle as big boss
because they they really hey don't sound
a thing a lot but it might just all be
political
maybe David Hayter screwed someone's
wife and the producer was like yeah he's
off the project I just don't know but
I'm gonna continue to tell myself that
it does make sense to not have David
Hayter in the game because of how the
voices should sound at this point
however I am going to miss David haters
voice it's not the same without him the
dudes have been snakes since 1998 just
write that off without fans being sad he
will most certainly be missed by every
Metal Gear Solid fan that lives and
probably the rest who do not live
anymore right so David Hayter not being
the voice of big boss do you think it's
an okay call to make you think it makes
sense what do you think it's complete
across the board whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]